hi I'm Erik Bosse and fantastic beats
the crimes of granite Wald released its
final trailer and of course it's one of
those insane super Cudi trailers that
bombards us with blink length frames and
things we don't understand makes my job
so fun let's go through this frame by
frame to try to explain all the stuff
that you missed in spoiler warning in
case you don't want to know so as always
this is just a highlighter but whatever
that leo ho dress i'm saying a safe
house in paris why would i need a safe
house in paris should things at some
point go terribly wrong it's good to
have a place to go you know for a cup of
tea
okay this trailer opens with a magic of
a different kind
practical sleight of hand so clever we
so newt holding the same card from
Dumbledore in the last trailer and now
we know it's an address for a safe house
in Paris I'm assuming it's the home
address of Nicolas Flamel notice the
glowing symbol on this card the last
trailer Dumbledore tapped that card I
assume that that symbol disappeared when
he did that kind of like that obscure Oh
spell that was used on the marauders map
this symbols color is in gold the same
substance full-mouth philosopher's stone
can turn any metal into and it has a
circular shape at the bottom kind of
assembled the resurrection stone one of
the Deathly Hallows which like the
Philosopher's Stone is one of those
nifty things that helps you overcome
death I also like that Dumbledore
suggests this would be a place for a cup
of tea
clematis Philosopher's Stone would be
used to brew the elixir of life which is
the substance you drink to become
immortal so I would definitely take up
this guy on that cup of tea Newt let's
move on my brothers
my sisters the clock is ticking fast
my dream we who live in this clip we'll
hear Gellert Grindelwald speech which is
actually the same speech Johnny Depp
delivered to that audience at comic-con
it's interesting that he tells his
followers that they are the ones who
live for truth in love
he's referring to the idea that wizards
shouldn't live in the shadows they
should be truthful and honest about
their actual superiority over the muggle
race and I'm sure part of his argument
will be based on the recent muggle great
war that just tore Europe apart he could
point to that and say muggles are all
about hate but this kind of double speak
actually evokes author George Orwell who
at 1984 and that book the Ministry of
Truth and ministry of love were actually
ministry it's responsible for the
opposite of those values mystery of
truth spread lies and propaganda and
fake news history and Ministry of love
tortured people so if you look at it
that way yeah Gellert Grindelwald and
his people might be all about truth we
also see the beginnings of Grindelwald
escape from acusa and new york from that
nighttime carriage thestral flight and
if he waits in a cell you can see a fly
buzzing toward him triggering these
enchantments that surround him to keep
him from escaping and before we move on
we get another shot of Tina Goldstein
and that enchanted statue in Paris now
I've said that this could lead to the
French Ministry of Magic but I could
also see that being the secret entrance
to the Parisian Diagon Alley let me know
you think well let's move on the moment
has come to take okay here is the
biggest reveal of this trailer
confirmation of the theory that's been
floating around online for months that
Claudia Kim's character afflicted with a
maledictis curse transforming her
gradually into a snake is actually
Nagini the snake who later becomes one
of bull der mort's Horcruxes when asked
about this on Twitter JK Rowling claims
she know about this backstory for 20
years and before interviews for
overthinking this in a wondering wait
does this mean Neville Longbottom
murdered a woman did Roly just rewrite
everything hold sacred
relax a maledictis curse is not the same
thing as an animagus which is a wizard
that can shape-shift into an animal at
will remember like Sirius Black I think
we can assume that by the time the human
Nagini turns into snake Nagini she stays
that way she becomes an animal and she
has a whole other animal life beyond
this and considering the modern-day
Harry Potter is more than a couple
generations in the future I'm assuming
some kind of magic makes her more than
just
normal snake too so really there's no
reason to doubt that she's later somehow
ends up in Albania where according to
the current backstory
Voldemort finds her later turning the
animal into a Horcrux hopefully that
cleared some stuff up on to the next
clip
Oh die okay here we get more shots of
Grindelwald dairy and escaped from
custody and we actually get some clues
of how he pulls it off now check out
this dude evening bitten it's hard to
tell but judging from that dark hair I'm
thinking this could be Abernathy the
Mikasa or from the first fantastic
pieces he could be a covert disciple of
Grindelwald or maybe he's just under the
Imperius curse he would have access to
Grindelwald Swan which would have gotten
confiscated and perhaps he's using it
here to free this captive or maybe
return it to Grindelwald so great a wall
can wiped out all these or escorts Wow
let's move on The Wizarding of non
Wizarding whales have been a peaceful
over a century
Windell Wald wants to see that piece
destroyed you want me to hunt him down
okay this section brings us back to
Hogwarts with a shot of Leda Lestrange
rim in the scene in the Great Hall of
the school now notice the floating
candles that's probably a throwback to
the candles on the very first Harry
Potter movie back in those days the
candles were actually real practical
effect
these are CGI but whatever it makes you
feel something about the past so it's
good we get another shot of Grindelwald
surrounded by the blue flame and his
Colosseum flanked by vin de rozier she's
holding that skull I pointed out before
I actually think that could be the skull
of Salazar Slytherin himself remember
that was the same head that provided Tom
Riddle with the inspiration for the
Death Eaters symbol we see a
mountainside exploding that could be set
in the Pyrenees I just think that
because that's the mountain range on the
border of France and Spain where the
French Wizarding school beauxbatons is
located or it could be a mountain range
in Bavaria near where Grindelwald
fortress NAM guard is supposed to be
located also interesting details of the
voiceover we're hearing here saying that
the Wizarding non Wizarding worlds have
been at peace for over a century
that means wizards and muggles were at
war a hundred years before this that
would places sometime early in the 19th
century there was a few important things
going on in European history at that
time there was apollyon ik wars but also
there was the Industrial Revolution
where new technology was replacing
agrarian economies with machines and
factories just a theory here maybe a
consequence of this muggle wizard war in
the past was Wizards granting muggles
forms of technology that will have their
society to take great strides forward
and then eventually engineer bombs and
weapons to destroy themselves in the
First World War all connected we also
see this shot of Tina dealing with this
fantastic beast escaped from the circus
our canis according to Rowling this is
something called a zoo whoo a beast from
Chinese mythology that's an elephant
sized cat with five colors we see this
thing show up again later in the trailer
we also again see these black cloths
blanketing Paris past I speculated that
these could be left folders or people
consuming beasts that have to be warded
off with a Patronus charm I'm thinking
they actually might be something else
more on that theory later before we move
on we see Newt here being tasked with
hunting down Grindelwald
now based on the wall tiles behind him
that is definitely the British Ministry
of Magic I assume he's arguing with his
brother
Theseus here moving on
to kill him
[Music]
dunwood are why can't you go I got
another guy's crinkles
it has to be here
in this section we see Newton Tina
happening upon this underground lair
where someone perhaps people speculated
Youssef , has been piecing together the
wizard family tree that we saw in past
footage and again if you look at that
family tree closely
it appears that Lidl estranged and
Creedence bare bones are related then
there's this interesting shot of queenie
reaching out to this bird imprint i'm
not sure what this means but i have a
feeling it is connected to Lidl
estranged only because there were some
posters that were just released for all
the characters and litas had a similar
bird symbol in the corner of it this
bird actually comes the bleeder in the
trailer hold on your beds and there's a
quick shot of nicholas flamel apparently
present at the same big showdown setting
with blue flames and we've seen other
characters in and then another shot of
Dumbledore's seeing Grindelwald in the
mirror of Erised said which i also went
into the last breakdown but check this
out we briefly see the younger versions
of the men and Albus and Gellert are
played by these same actors that play
the young men in Deathly Hallows so I'm
thinking if these actors are involved I
could see this movie revealing the
flashback of what exactly went down with
Dumbledore sister Ariana we will see
moving on
you don't have a motion sickness to see
I don't do well on boats
Ginuwine I admire you Nick
you do not seek power you simply ask is
the thing right here it appears as
though Newton Jacob are using this
bucket maybe as a port key notice how
that cliffside is white colored this
could be taking place at Dover which is
right across the English Channel from
France you can actually see it from
Dover so maybe this exact point it's
kind of a point of entry for wizards
between the two countries next we see
Newt using some kind of powder to
conjure this image of another beast and
to me this looks like a cap up which is
a Japanese water demon that actually
came up in the earlier films and it's
one of the attractions at the circus
arcane is a capa feeds off human blood
but you can appease it by tossing it a
cucumber inscribed with your name or you
can trick it into bowing and spilling
the water in its head that'll apparently
weaken it wizard things then there's
that dude in the Hat whom we've seen
chasing credence past trailers perhaps
this is the Spielman character over is
it screaming himself into a wall jesu is
what it looks like when kids tried to
force their way into that column between
platforms 9 and 10 at Kings Cross want
to believe and speaking of creepy walls
Nagini touches a wall and has another
hand stranger things through and grab
her look at that wallpaper
it's a flower but the stem forms a
v-shape I mean if this is the crest for
vinda Rossier with a V and a rose
I guess rose petals don't really look
like that look I'm trying okay and we
see Newt calming the zulu with a fluffy
play toy at the end of his wand picket
ruining newts coat and then a shot of
new to merge in from a suitcase to find
Tina I notice the set in here the flasks
the multiple Globes yes this is the home
of Nicolas Flamel
Tina appears to be reading through Nikki
flames notes previously have speculated
this movie could be a sort of race to
immortality one side collecting Hallows
the other side crazy old alchemists
magic rock even if this movie isn't that
I would very much like to see that movie
moving on
the times coming when you have to pick a
side
[Music]
site
[Music]
here after some shots of Newt writing a
kelpy there's this interesting shot of
him looking up at some warplanes in a
dogfight over a bombed out rubble
notice how this battle almost looks like
it's being seen through a grey filter so
I'm wondering if those black cloths that
covered the city aren't let the folds
what if there's some kind of magical
enchantment protecting in The Wizard
World of Paris from the war and
destruction of the muggle world up above
like maybe these blankets come down
whenever there's an air-raid I guess to
be clear this movie is set in 1927 which
is really between world wars not during
but this would be a very cool way to
justify how the Wizarding World was able
to stay out of the human wars that
ravaged to the European cities next
there's this crazy shot of some kind of
portal opening and the French Ministry
this could be one of the abilities of
the zoo which you can see with this main
all illuminated there and if you look
closely he's being pursued by the meta
goes those are the black cat like
creatures he's by the french ministry
that we saw the last trailer and as new
tells his brother Theseus also drew
Sarge there's a quick shot of Hogwarts
students running around the corner of
the grounds and you can see the
Quidditch pitch in the background maybe
this is part of the flashback we're
revealing the incident that caused newts
expulsion then there's a shot of Newton
Tina apparently having snuck into this
Coliseum location with Grindelwald
followers and look at those statues to
me those look like tombs the top each
one is a giant bird actually it looks a
lot like the bird Queen II was looking
at earlier don't know what this means
only that it could be connected
moving on mute you never met a monster
you couldn't love I stake
okay there is the last have to look at
here first we know that there's going to
be some kind of showdown moment in
Grindelwald Coliseum with all the key
players there noot Tina
Lida Grindelwald bend credence Nagini
and Theseus maybe also Nikki flame we
see images of the scrander brothers
together fighting off Grindelwald x'
blue flame just speculate before could
be fiend fire with their own fire spell
there's also a shot of these windows
being bashed out notice the mountainous
background I'm thinking this could be
the interior angle of the cliffside
explosion that we saw earlier this could
be some kind of hidden magical structure
in a mountain range
there's also Dumbledore in his classroom
perhaps some doing whatever fantastic
beast the Boggart turned it's up into
afternoon ridiculous to his greatest
fear of desk work by the way there's no
way all those students are the same year
why are they in the same class what's
going on okay I'm becoming the cynic
that I hate let's move on to the final
clip
I think that might've been the best
moment of mine we get this movie's title
with the smoke once again forming the
shape of the deathly hallows with the
deathly hallows also hidden in the
letters of the title knee though in all
plays under very avengers ii arrangement
of the Harry Potter theme because epic I
guess the final clip shows Tina subdue
enthusiasts in the French Ministry two
newts delight and if you look closely
you can actually see her blocking an
attack from Theseus from behind he tries
to launch a pile of suitcases at them as
they run but she is just too bad my
question for you guys about this trailer
would you have preferred Nikki knees
reveal being saved for the movie or just
knowing it ahead of time get you more
excited to see it comment down below
with your thoughts and follow me on
twitter and instagram at a boss and if
you love Harry Potter and you happen to
live in the LA area you should come
check out my live parody show called
infinity fan where I joke about Harry
Potter but also Marvel Star Wars game of
Thrones everything you could possibly be
a fan of there will be time Turner's in
this show so you know it's gonna be
crazy
show details of ticket info are in the
description below and subscribe to new
rock stars for more deep dives to know
all the stuff that you love mischief
managed now it's just a mischief
highlighted highlight it thanks
[Music]